Green Shadow Warrior 2 is a game that we
both played and I think it's really cool
and that's why I want to talk to you
about it today what did you think of it
I was actually quite pleasantly
surprised I have not played any of the
Shadow Warrior games before I had heard
about them and I watched some of the
trailers in the gameplays and it looks
really interesting to me like I was like
whoa where did this game come from so
this is Shadow Warrior 2 which is a
sequel to a reboot of Shadow Warrior
which was a 1997 first-person shooter
made by 3d realms who also made things
like Wolfenstein duke nukem most
famously but this one Shadow Warrior 2
is taking things in a slightly different
direction whereas the first reboot
focused on a linear story which followed
the adventures of lo Wang this one is a
much more open RPG style fps in the vein
of Borderlands and that's one of the
things that I wanted to talk about that
sets it apart from other first-person
shooter games because you know there is
like a loot system there's a crafting
system there's a questing system which
is kind of bizarre to me because Shadow
Warrior to me was kind of this all this
like all about stupid visceral
unapologetically dumb in its humor yeah
like it makes Wang jokes they make
frantic
it's very exploitation style it's like
over-the-top violence over-the-top jokes
and they throw a lot of things that
don't always stick that you know is in
this is in the spirit the whole thing
yeah and like it's something that you
know like as soon as you start well as
soon as I started playing the game like
I thought okay like that's what this
game is gonna be about and that's kind
of like the expectation so I thought
like since all the humor and the style
of everything was shallow
that's the gameplay would follow suit
and also be shallow but it was
surprisingly deeper than that instead
there's like damaged numbers and like an
elemental system and yeah let's go into
some of that some live like let's go
into like the weapons and stuff I ended
up using the katanas a lot yeah
because even though they're melee
weapons they don't underpowered
competitive guns but they made the
katana is kind of like powerful enough
to make you want to keep using them
which is cool I love melee in
first-person
is mainly because you know they usually
so underpowered and I just like punching
guys in the face but the melee system in
shut away - you know like Shadow Warrior
1 is actually really great so like you
said there were the dual katana and
there were the Wolverine claws which
I've kind of preferred and the thing I
really liked about them is that you know
they had a variety of special moves so
you could charge up left or right and do
like an attack you could charge forward
and do like a really great lunge and
like just dig into your enemies you
could hold back and you know send off a
sort of wave so your melee actually had
a sub ranged component to it if you
needed it and the thing I liked about it
also was that coupled with the movement
system which was also super fun so you
can kind of like err - anywhere mid jump
and there's no sort of stamina so it's
kind of unlimited there being really
agile with the melee was just just made
the game so fun to make the player and
also the fact that you know you could
switch between guns and and melee very
quickly and in doing so you you know
came off with another attack so you were
never sort of caught in a bad situation
that's right and I think that's one of
the things that the game did very well
that I experienced because it was like
it had this nice flow to it right like
you're always running you're jumping in
clambering up roof so you're never
really stopping even when you're
fighting monsters all the big fights
would happen like in these large arenas
we got plenty of room feat like run
around and like maneuver yourself one
thing we should mention is that the guns
also had elemental damage which is not
something I really saw the advantage of
in this demo that we played because we
got all the weapons and we weren't
really caring about loot and that kind
of stuff and we didn't really mess
around with the crafting slash
customizations as to me though although
I did notice that I'm certain Damon's
like the bosses and stuff they have text
underneath their health bars that say
things like weak to frost or strong
against lightning yeah so you know at
those mums I would pull out like a gun
that had frost ammo in it I guess yeah
or I would use the bird that had
lightning on it like that kind of stuff
I can imagine like doing more
it's obviously something that they're
really gonna dive deep into I see you
but it's not something we could really
assess no not at this point not when we
were just overpowered and like didn't
really have to worry about all that
stuff at that point in time I just like
pull out my clothes won't everything it
was really fun so let's talk about the
move to an open-world RPG and sort of
the the loss of you know a storyline as
far as we could see I mean there is
still a storyline there is like the main
quest storyline which you have to follow
you want to progress but there is still
room for you to golf and do side
missions if you want to just hoard loot
and stuff there's a lot of like go here
to collect this oh absolutely but that
being said like I only had like an hour
with the game I don't know like the
character who you're paired with this
time around
Kumiko I believe her name is she just
grated on my nerves honestly I mean at
the end of the day it's a like as soon
as you get into it you know what you're
getting yourself into
yeah like same with like it was kind of
like Duke Nukem 3d right like you know
what you're there to kill a bunch of
dudes and you know that could style of
FPS is definitely coming back what we've
doomed recently being rebooted so I'm
definitely looking forward to playing a
lot more sure warrior 2 just because it
feels so good to kill things yeah it
takes that and it doesn't really well
with the boat you get away